um first of all how many Brits are on
the planes that have come out of Sudan
well the we've commenced an evacuation
mission in the last 24 48 Hours
um and we expect there to be
approximately 200 to 300 people who have
been uh relocated from Sudan in the last
few flights but we are now commencing a
an extensive operation working with over
a thousand Personnel from the RAF and
the Armed Forces uh the home officers
sent out officials from border Force to
help with the processing and this whole
operation is being coordinated by the
foreign office with leadership from the
Prime Minister Germany's foreign
minister says they would never leave
their citizens to their own devices in
Sudan unlike other countries
obviously you dig at the Brits what
would you say in response to that well I
would refute that suggestion that that
is a criticism of the United Kingdom
we're very diff we're in a very
different situation to other countries
we've got a larger cohort of British
Nationals in Sudan compared to many
other countries we have an extensive
operation to support diplomats but also
British passport holders British
Nationals their dependents and we've
commenced our evacuation uh Mission and
it's in process as we speak after a lot
of many other countries
uh listen there has been a very serious
situation in Sudan it's been escalating
uh over several days we welcome the
ceasefire that is currently uh there the
UK has been pivotal uh in those
discussions we want to maintain that
Seaside but people's lives have been in
danger we now have an operation which is
up and running which is going to be
supporting uh British Nationals why did
we bring civilians out earlier we want
to support what we we are that is what
we are doing I think we can quibble
about uh
times but what we're actually doing here
is setting out an extensive program of
support we've put in over a thousand
Armed Forces Personnel who are out there
we are we are doing it now uh we have
been working on this for several days
the Germans say we were we were slower
Germans and French were bringing out
British citizens because we weren't
doing it I don't think it's right to
make this some kind of competition we've
got a very different territory lives the
UK has a very different scenario and
community and cohort in terms of numbers
compared to other countries we've been
the UK government has been overseeing
and monitoring the situation very
closely for weeks now a decision has
been made on the back of proper planning
proper assessment of the security and
risk posed in Sudan and we now have an
in-flight operation to evacuate still
having to make their own way still
having to make their own way to the
airport so they're still in as much
danger there's a ceasefire in place but
it's it's a it's a Lucy swine
well we are we are now removing
relocating British Nationals and their
dependence well that is the assessment
based on
um security uh matters which have
informed that decision this is a a
standard practice in terms of the advice
that the foreign office is issuing to
British Nationals it is context specific
it is highly dependent on the very
sensitive and changing and fast-moving
circumstances in Sudan I'm not going to
sit here in a studio in London and say
that and dictate what uh what should be
happening there on the ground we are in
close contact the government is in close
contact uh with the Armed Forces who are
assessing the situation we've got to
weigh up uh a lot of very complex
factors before decisions like this are
made bearing in mind the numbers that
we're dealing with but what is clear is
that we are we have started an
evacuation Mission British Nationals
have got support from the foreign office
in the UK here this is a developing
crisis people will end up Crossing in
small boats to the UK from Sudan what
are you going to do with them
well again I mean I I wouldn't want to
necessarily make that an inevitability
there is a global migration of Crisis
what are we going to do there is a
global migration crisis
people with our position in Sudan is
that we are supporting British Nationals
British passport holders and their
depends in terms of secretary I'm asking
what's happening what's going to happen
to people who turn up who tip up in
Dover on a small boat from Sudan well
that's why we are passing a new law at
the moment to deal with people who come
here illegally no one there is no good
reason for anybody to get into a small
boat and cross the channel in search of
a life in the United Kingdom if you are
someone who is fleeing Sudan for
humanitarian reasons there are various
mechanisms you can use I the unhcr is
present in the region and they are the
right mechanism by which people should
apply if they do want to seek asylum in
the United States okay let me ask you
about Robert genre
um he said yesterday that people fleeing
from Sudan and others are uncontrolled
illegal migration is how he described it
he said that they threatened to
cannibalize the UK's compassion
essentially calling migrants
sub-human he was saying that they don't
adopt our values
I think that the point that the minister
is making is that unprecedented and
uncontrolled levels of immigration into
the United Kingdom are unsustainable and
unacceptable I think that's what the
vast majority of British people were
adopting I think what we are seeing is
an unacceptable level of people coming
here illegally uh 45 000 people coming
here without a right to be we only have
a very nice amount of time uh
homosexuality if you can answer my
question what did he mean by not
adopting our values yeah people who are
coming here illegally are breaking our
laws they are criminals and they don't
have a right to be here that is at odds
with our values of upholding the rule of
law generosity people who come here it's
not illegal is it to come here on a boat
we've had this discussion before yeah
and we disagree it is illegal to get on
a boat to come here illegally you don't
have ring people legal permission to get
on one of the boats you don't have a
legal right to be in the United Kingdom
it is not a lawful means of entry and we
have lawful and safe routes of Entry
whereby people are issued visas or they
are issued permissions to come that is
the way people should apply to come into
the United Kingdom not on a boat
surreptitiously dangerously fatally so
as we saw at the end of last year where
they're being exploited by evil people
smuggling better to stay in Sudan with
the Warlords fighting against each other
how confident are you that your plan to
get around the European judges and the
British laws in your immigration bill
which we'll hear more about will work
well we've introduced our bill it's now
nearing completion in the Commons today
is our final stage of debate today yeah
and we've introduced some Clauses to uh
to enable a greater decision-making
power on the part of the Home Secretary
so we avoid a scenario that we saw last
June whereby the Home Secretary made a
decision to relocate people from the
United Kingdom people who had arrived
here illegally to Rwanda English courts
had upheld that decision and at the 11th
Hour a judge in Strasbourg pursuant to
an opaque process whereby the United
Kingdom was not represented undermined
that decision that's totally
unacceptable from a democratic point of
view and we have introduced a clause
which enables the Home Secretary to
consider the case uh on its individual
merits and have a discretion to possibly
avoid that scenario replaying again
we're struggling for time but I know you
want to talk about policing numbers as
well you'll tell me that the numbers
have gone up but they're still lower
than uh 2010 levels aren't they
well we we are confident that we're on
track to reach our Target our Manifesto
pledge of recruiting 20 000 new police
officers if we achieve that 21 000
previously if we achieve that goal we
will be uh in excess of 2010 numbers we
will be at record levels we will have
the highest number of police officers in
history in England and Wales I think
that's a huge achievement at the moment
a big achievement by the home office
actually and actually a great
achievement for the British people and
Public Safety because so many police
officers are retiring
um 40 percent of the police officers in
this country have not been serving for
up to five years
um we have an inexperienced police force
now I disagree with that we've put in
three billion pounds to support this
unprecedented and massive recruitment
effort uh the new recruits all have the
proper training and we are ensuring that
on a net assessment we will have uh and
we're confident of reaching our Target
over of the highest number of police
officers on record so even accounting
for attrition and people leaving the
force we are confident we'll still be in
excess of any level that we've seen
before I think that is really good for
the British public they will see more
police on the beat they will see more
police responding to anti-social
Behavior violence and theft and burglary
that's what the British people and
that's what this government said the
question before I let you go you're
heading to Northampton today I believe
just to see some new police officers on
the beat and otherwise you said that
they should no longer Pander to
political correctness what did you mean
well I think uh whilst our police
officers are brave and uh excellent on
the whole I think there has been a
tendency for uh the public to grow weary
of uh some of the uh time wasting uh
behavior that police have been engaged
in so I don't want the police to be
engaged in uh politically uh debates on
social media about gender I don't want
the police to shut be shying away from
tackling really important issues like
grooming gangs because of political
correctness I don't want the police to
be uh you know not I want the police to
be using their stop and search Powers
because that's an effective tool to
reduce violence and save lives and um in
in some instances we've seen political
correctness get in the way of Common
Sense policing
full and honest answers as usual thanks
very much indeed for joining us on the
program thank you home secretary